non le monsieur s'arrange à l'amiable
montre-moi les papiers du véhicule
voilà merci c'est bien gentil allez-y
fini oui bah voilà je l'ai déchiré
la façon dont on avait parlé j'ai pas du
tout apprécié qu'est-ce que je vous
avais dit
moi
je connais je suis bien placé
là vous êtes mal garés alors j'attends
de conduire
alors elle est bonne celle-là
parce que c'est celui de du monsieur
d'avance c'est un faux
là logique moi c'est moi qui suis
logique vous êtes illogique vous êtes
garé comme un cochon
alors un cheval vous êtes garé comme un
cheval sortez du véhicule
il y a pas de raison que je sois sous la
pluie et pas vous
alors
[Musique]